jean vous êtes une une star de
l'académie donc on va vous faire une
interview star académie française
alors on va comparer un petit peu la
star ac et l'académie à la star academy
et l'académie française est-ce que de la
meuf à la cades est évidemment bien là
me bats pour cause et même moi qui l'a
fait entrer sur saône à un dur sonore
via ce1 nous rappeler bien se voit qui
est fait entre m la première fois mal
accueilli
vous vous rappelez qui avait toute la
presse pas seulement parisienne mais
française et mondiale et à la fin on m'a
demandé alors qu'est ce qui a changé à
l'académie et j'ai répondu
maintenant il y aura deux toilettes sur
lui nuire a écrit messieurs et sur
l'autre marguerite yourcenar et depuis
j'ai vu d'autres
il ya eu romy vivent également madame de
romilly qui est une merveille ya
florence delay il ya notre secrétaire
perpétuel de la meurthe là tu voi et pas
que des tons la star ac et l'académie
française c'est la même chose est ce
qu'il ya des couples qui se sont formés
à l'académie france assure le maire en
mai défaire recevrait ne devenez pas des
détails
est ce que à l'académie française comme
en astarac vous pouvez perdre votre
place à tout moment à nos un peu ça non
pour toujours impossible ouais ça ne
peut pas justement il y à des ombres il
peut pas être viré vis à vis il ya des
embrouilles entre académiciens des
embrouilles
mais oui souvent ils se détestent ouais
un tel bord ils sont tous habillés
pareil ouais on vers connais pas le
choix est-ce que ça parle beaucoup dans
le dos des autres comme la star ac oui
jean c'est loin vous avez une salle de
sport bah non non
salle csa non non on pourrait
on pourrait s qu'il ya beaucoup de
prétendants et peu d'élus oui oui tout
le monde
ouais tout le monde veut y aller tous
ces qui marche 1 nous sommes 40
il n'y a pas de prochain y'a pas trop ça
ya pas deux prochaines années un qui
meurt il faut attendre qu'on ne souhaite
pas mais il en mourra sûrement très vite
il en meurt trois est-ce qu'ils avaient
un prof de diction à l'académie
française
je vous donnais des cours de diction
j'adorerais
est-ce que vous pouvez vous exclure les
uns les autres en votant non ah non on
peut exclure on peut exclure les
candidats ouais mais il va cogner c'est
fini alors est-ce que c'est comme à la
star ac il ya toujours un noir un conte
un belge une big moe une douche et un
nul pour que le monde entier puisse se
reconnaître non alors un coup sûrement
un belge à la même c'est une bimbo à
wigan est une douce
oui oui un nul est-ce que c'est comme à
la star actuellement nous oublient au
bout de deux ans à l'académie française
non non non pas du tout non ça n'a pas
duré longtemps puisque avec l'immortel
ça va immortel on est tranquille je
viens par crois que vous êtes vraiment
immortel non mais vous savez la
définition c'était on les dit mortelle
pour la durée de notre vie et après on
se change au fauteuil gens dorment ce
temps là c'est publié chez robert
laffont m messieurs